The women told me,
"You'll adjust to this place.
You'll fit right in."
I was no longer referred to as Teresa Njoroge.
The number 415/11 was my new identity,
and I soon learned that was the case with the other women
who we were sharing this space with.
And adjust I did to life on the inside:
the prison food,
the prison language,
the prison life.
Prison is certainly no fairytale world.
What I didn't see come my way
was the women and children
whom we served time and shared space with,
women who had been imprisoned
for crimes of the system,
the corruption that requires a fall guy,
a scapegoat,
so that the person who is responsible
could go free,
a broken system that routinely vilifies the vulnerable,
the poorest amongst us,
people who cannot afford to pay bail
or bribes.
And so we moved on.
As I listened to story after story
of these close to 700 women
during that one year in prison,
I soon realized that crime
was not what had brought these women to prison,
most of them,
far from it.
It had started with the education system,
whose supply and quality is not equal for all;
lack of economic opportunities
that pushes these women to petty survival crimes;
the health system,
social justice system,
the criminal justice system.
If any of these women,
who were mostly from poor backgrounds,
fall through the cracks
in the already broken system,
the bottom of that chasm is a prison,
period.
By the time I completed my one-year sentence
at Langata Women Maximum Prison,
I had a burning conviction
to be part of the transformation
to resolve the injustices
that I had witnessed
of women and girls
who were caught up in a revolving door
of a life in and out of prison
due to poverty.
After my release,
I set up Clean Start.
Clean Start is a social enterprise
that seeks to give these women and girls
a second chance.
What we do is we build bridges for them.
We go into the prisons, train them,
give them skills, tools and support
to enable them to be able to change their mindsets,
their behaviors and their attitudes.
We also build bridges into the prisons
from the corporate sector --
individuals, organizations
that will partner with Clean Start
to enable us to provide employment,
places to call home,
jobs, vocational training,
for these women, girls,
boys and men,
upon transition back into society.
I never thought
that one day
I would be giving stories
of the injustices that are so common
within the criminal justice system,
but here I am.
Every time I go back to prison,
I feel a little at home,
but it is the daunting work
to achieve the vision
that keeps me awake at night,
connecting the miles to Louisiana,
which is deemed as the incarceration capital of the world,
carrying with me stories
of hundreds of women
whom I have met within the prisons,
some of whom are now embracing their second chances,
and others who are still on that bridge of life's journey.
I embody a line
from the great Maya Angelou.
"I come as one,
but I stand as 10,000."
(Applause)
For my story is singular,
but imagine with me
the millions of people
in prisons today,
yearning for freedom.
Three years post my conviction
and two years post my release,
I got cleared by the courts of appeal
of any wrongdoing.
(Applause)
Around the same time,
I got blessed with my son,
whom I named Uhuru,
which in my dialect means "freedom."
(Applause)
Because I had finally gotten the freedom
that I so longed for.
I come as one,
but I stand as 10,000,
encouraged by the hard-edged hope
that thousands of us have come together
to reform and transform the criminal justice system,
encouraged that we are doing our jobs
as we are meant to do them.
And let us keep doing them
with no apology.
Thank you.
(Applause)